اذا نبدا في المتابعه مع مراسلين نذهب الى
كيف معنا من هناك حذيفه عادل حذيفه اهلا
بك معنا بدايه كيف تلقت اكياد هذه الرساله
رساله واشنطن ببدء الهجوم المضاد قبل
معركه الربيع وكذلك الاحاديث حول احتماليه
قطع المساعدات العسكريه عنها
تحياتي صهيب في الحقيقه في اطار تغطيه هذه
القضيه ومتابعه هذا الموضوع تحديدا قرات
تعليقات لخبراء عسكريين ومراقبين هي جديره
بالاهتمام حول ما اذا كان هذه التصريحات
من قبل الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وحتى
التصريحات التي تصدر منك باستعجال الامداد
العسكري ونقص الذخيره وما الى ذلك انه
يعني في ذات اتجاه الخدعه في الحرب وان
كييف وعمليه التوصيل
الاسلحه والمعدات هي جاريه بالفعل وهنالك
تنسيق دقيق بين النيتو وبين الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه وبين اوكرانيا وجاري
فعلا عمليه توصيل الاسلحه الى داخل
الاراضي الاوكرانيه ويستشهدون في ذلك طبعا
بالهجوم المضاده الذي قامت به اوكرانيا في
استعاده السيطره على خاوف عندما كان
الاعلان عن استعاده السيطره في اخر ولكن
على ايه حال الم عنه الان انه في الاسبوع
القادم سوف تبدا فرنسا
بتسليم الدبابات ام اكس 10 وكذلك ينهي
الجنود الاوكرانيين التدريباتهم في
الاسابيع القليله القادمه ومع ذلك تبدا
عمليه توصيل الدبابات والاسلحه الموجوده
بها
ابقى معنا حذيفه ينضم الينا الان مراسلنا
في دنيا قراءه الاغبر رائد مرحبا بك معنا
بدايه كان هناك اليوم قصف على التفاصيل لو
سمحت
صهيب بالفعل يعني عاده القوات الاوكرانيه
لتقصف قلب المدينه او العاصمه دانيتك قتيل
واحد عشر اصابه حصيله القصف لهذا اليوم
والقصف استهدف مناطق مختلفه مدنيه وحكوميه
بالفعل 45 صاروخ وقذيفه مره واحده اربعين
صاروخ جراد او فامبير التشيكيه وبولنديه
صنع استهدفت قلب المدينه وخمسه قذائف من
عيار 155 وهي امترابل سفن القذائف
الامريكيه التي تطلق من مدافع هاوزر
بالفعل رغم الحديث عن ضعف امكانات
العسكريه الاوكرانيه خلال الفتره الماضيه
بالذخيره اي ان المستودعات باتت خاويه
وخاليه من الذخيره عاده اليوم اوكرانيا
لتقصف من جديد المناطق المدنيه ايضا هناك
عمليات الاجلاء على اطراف المقاطعه حول
باخمه يعني صرح عمده المدينه بانه تتم
عمليات اجلاء للمدنيين المقيمين في
البلدات المتاخمه لباخمت وايضا من الناحيه
الغربيه اي في وسط باخموت ايضا هناك
عمليات اجلاء للاوكرانيين للناحيه
الاوكرانيه لابد ان هناك شيء ما كبير يحضر
له عمليه عسكريه كبيره حول
النقطه فعلا رائد ساودي اليك في مساله ما
الشيء الذي يحضر له ولكن لن يسالك حذيفه
تحدث عن الدبابات الفرنسيه التي ستبدا في
الوصول الى اوكرانيا وكذلك هذه المطالبه
الامريكيه للاوكرانيين ببدء هجوم مضاد
حدثني عن باخمت ماذا تقول بان هذه المعركه
هي مهمه جدا في حسم هذه المعركه هذه الحرب
ماذا تقول اوكرانيا عن وضع قواتها
المدافعه عن باخموت وهل هناك استعدادات
اوكرانيه فعلا لبدء هجوم مضاد ضد تحضر له
روسيا
اولا صهيب اوكرانيا تستخدم باخموت لتعطيل
جيش الاتحاد الروسي من التقدم حتى وصول
الامدادات هذا تصريح واضح من القاده
العسكريين حول انه لم يسمحوا بدخول على
الرغم من ان الشركاء الغربيين والمستشارين
الغربيين نصحوا كيف بيع الانسحاب نسبه
للذخيره الهائله والكبيره التي يستخدمها
الجيش الاوكراني للصد الهجمات القويه من
قبل الاتحاد الروسي لكن اليوم يعني اذا
تحدثنا عن قائد كتيبه الاستطلاعات
الاستطلاع في باخبوت نشر فيديو على مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي تحدث بشكل واضح عن ان
الوضع صعب جدا وقاسي جدا وان الهجوم من
الجهات الثلاث من الشرق ومن الجنوب ومن
الشمال تبقى الجهه الغربيه فقط التي لا
تقوم القوات الروسيه بشن هجمات منها ولكنه
ايضا اكد ان الدفاعات الهندسيه والقوات
الاوكرانيه قادره على اي هجمات وان القوات
الروسيه لن تدخل الى هذه المدينه في الوقت
الحالي وهو لذلك نعم رائد ماذا عنك هناك
حديث عن استعدادات تحشيد عسكري كبير جدا
روسي في دنيا
وايضا بنسبه اقل فيا ما حقيقه هذا
يعني بالفعل صهيب تعتبر منطقه
الاكثر سخونه
وتشهد معارك ضاريه على حدودها الجنوبيه
وشماليه حيث اجلادار في الجنوب وفي الشمال
باقمت هناك حضور كبير واعداد كبيره من
جنود الذين قدموا من موسكو بعد التعبئه
الجزئيه التي اعلنت اواخر العام الماضي
بالفعل هناك حضور لسلاح الجو الروسي في
المنطقه دخول مقاتلات حديثه دخول دبابات
حديثه متطوره صواريخ نسمع اصوات ذوي
انفجارات مختلفه اقصد اطلاق النار من
القذائف والمدافع الروسيه الدوي مختلف عن
ما كنا نسمعه مع بدايه المعارك خلال العام
الماضي بالفعل دخلت اسلحه جديده في نطاق
العمليه العسكريه يعني موازاه او تزامنا
مع الدعم المنتظر القوات الاوكرانيه في
المنطقه الشماليه من دانياس وهي باخمه حيث
هناك تتم كما اسلفت لك عمليات اجلاء من
الطرفين الجانب الروسي والجانب الاوكراني
للسكان المدنيين وهذه اشاره كبيره الى ان
هناك معركه داميه ستكون في تلك المنطقه في
مدينه باقمت او حولها من دنيتك مراسله
العربيه شكرا جزيلا لكما رائد الاخبار
وحذيفه عادل